(audience applause)
- [Kelly] So I already
introduced you to Deon,
but I have to tell you that -
I know I wrote you this card backstage,
I don't know if you've read it yet -
but you, randomly, I don't think you know,
but you met my friend, Brynn Cartelli.
- [Cody] Yes!
- She was my Voice winner,
my first season on The
Voice and her mama, Deb.
And they were in New York city
and here's the test of a true kind person.
He didn't know them, like
whatever, but you took time
and you took a photo, its so,
it's so sweet!
(audience applause)
That's Brynn's mama, Deb,
and they're my friends
and they said you were so kind to them.
- They were so sweet, I remember.
My boyfriend lives like
right around the corner.
So we were just having dinner
and they were so sweet and-
- They were very excited and you were-
And I know that it sucks sometimes
when you're out to dinner
and you're like, I just want
to like live my life sometimes.
And it was just, but
it was very kind, like,
not everybody's that kind, so anyway,
I just want to say thank
you saying and being nice.
- Of course! It comes
with the territory, okay?
- Yeah, yeah.
Well what do you, do you like working out?
Do you Peloton?
Do you do anything like that?
- You said what?
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Nope.
- Peloton?
(laughter)
- Do you work out at
all? How do you work out?
Do you work out?
- Uh, yeah...
(audience laughter)
- And how so?
- I think you probably work
out as much as I do then.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
Carrying laundry to the laundry room.
(audience laughing)
- Hey, five minutes
with a towel.
- I just love it
cause my house is being
renovated right now.
So I'm like, oh, I can't, cause it's like,
everything's so messed up
right now so I can't work out.
It's like my, I will find an excuse.
But like Deon, you went through a lot
to get where you are today, right?
- Absolutely, you know,
growing up in Greensboro,
North Carolina it was
like, it was challenging.
My mom was a single parent.
She worked a lot of like blue collar jobs,
as a waitress, she worked at the Coliseum.
So, it was really
challenging growing up and
I'm always like, I look
back at that adversity
and I look at the things
that I went through.
- Mm.
- And I look at where, where I came from.
Like at a point we were homeless.
Like we were living in motels
or I was staying with parents,
parents of my friends.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you look back and you're like, wow.
That was a time that I was
really going through it.
But it always gave me that drive.
It always gave me that push that I knew
I never wanted to be in that place again.
(audience applause)
- I think that's how you
build such an amazing work ethic as well.
Because we, our family
was similar, like me,
my mom was single for
a good part of my life
when I was a kid and
so it made me watch her
work so hard.
- Yeah.
- And she was trying to
overcome so much and like,
it made me work really
hard and I really like,
that's why everybody's always
like, you have so many jobs!
I'm like, y'all, my
mom had all these jobs.
But everybody's got a lot of jobs, right?
(audience applause)
- Everybody got a lot of jobs!
- Everybody's trying to
hustle and make it happen.
But I think that it does
help you, don't you agree?
Like how you grow up, it
really just kind of molds you.
- Absolutely, yeah.
Because your path dictates
who you become, you know?
- [Cody] Absolutely.
- And then once you do
get it, you cherish it
in a way that other people
who was just given it to-
(audience applause)
- You almost feel sorry for them,
because they don't know the difference.
They don't.
And they don't even
appreciate it, it's just you-
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Absolutely do.
So you met one of your
idols recently, right?
- [Cody] Yes.
- Working? So wait, how
was it and who was it?
Tell everybody.
- Oh, so Mel C! Sporty Spice!
(audience cheering)
- Was (sighs) an icon.
- [Kelly] Still looks fantastic!
- [Cody] Amazing!
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- She is the hardest working
member of the Spice Girls.
So, you know, like, and it still shows,
it was just surreal
having this person I looked
up to and being on the
same show as her.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- And honestly, I loved sharing
this experience with her
because it's really, you've
done reality TV shows.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, it's nerve wracking.
You don't know what's going to happen
at the end of every episode.
- Mm-hmm.
- And so, what I loved
about having her by my side
was always talking about
like the nervousness
and the anxiety that we might
feel before we performed.
And I was like, if a Spice
Girl who sold out stadiums
is getting nervous, like
it's okay that I'm nervous,
you know.
- But everyone I talked to
that does these shows they always say,
it's just like the hardest thing ever.
Everyone.
- [Cody] It is grueling.
- It doesn't if matter
if it's like an Olympian
or a housewife, it
doesn't matter who it is.
They're all like, it's the
hardest thing ever schedule wise.
- [Cody] It is. It is crazy. Its like-
- Why did you sign up to do it?
That's my-
(audience laughs)
Like as soon as someone
says that I'm like, never,
I'm like nope.
(audience laughs)
- I hid, I hid that I liked their song.
- [Cody] Yeah?
- I hid that I liked that song.
- Oh, it was like a guilty pleasure?
- When it first came out.
- Oh yeah. What do you mean?
- I wouldn't let nobody know
that I loved it.
- If You Wanna Be My Lover?
- But you were turning it up.
You were turning up
Wannabe in the car.
- Yeah like my boys
would get in the car and I
be like, all right y'all,
I'll talk to y'all later.
♪ And I' ll tell you what
what I really really want ♪
(audience applause)
- Oh my god, I love it!
It reached everyone.
- [Cody] Everybody!
- It reached everyone.
Well, you had a Grease theme, so,
and there was a week on
Dancing With The Stars
where we did a Grease theme.
But actually that wasn't
your first time playing
a greaser.
- It was not.
- I think we have a clip.
- [Cody] Ahh, I knew this
was where this was going!
♪ Go grease lightning you're
burning up the quarter mile ♪
♪ Grease lighting, go grease lighting ♪
♪ Go grease lightning ♪
♪ You're coasting through
the heat lap trials ♪
♪ Grease lightning, go grease lightning ♪
(audience applause)
- Here's the thing.
I was a total choir kid too.
I did that move as well.
- Did you?
- I did that same thing.
I didn't look as cool, but I
didn't have a leather jacket.
I look like a hot mess, then too.
(Kelly laughing)
- Wow.
I mean, look at that hairstyle
and that very heteronormative
jean, you know like-
(everyone laughing)
It was, I wasn't in my groove just yet.
- Yeah.